When we encounter a stressful event there are two ways we can assess the event.
The first is called Primary Appraisal. Here we're talking about a quick
assessment of the meaning of a given environmental event for an individual. For
example you may become very stressed about the fact that your shower's broken
and you have to call somebody to get it fixed. And everything that it's
going to take to get the shower fixed, planning someone to fix it, having to
pay for it cleaning up the house so someone can come in. These things are
really stressful. So that might be the first reaction or assessment of what the
situation means to you. So the shower handle broke, so that means you're
going to have to do all of this other stuff just to fix it. So, this was an
example of primary appraisal, our first reaction or assessment of a situation
and what it means to us. Now, it's important to note, if we appraise the
situation as being contrary to our well-being, then it will produce a negative
emotion and the negative emotion can cause stress.